[Applause]
Megan Markel and Prince Harry are
ponying up in Scotland where plaid was
to be had and was there a hassle at a
castle we're spilling the royalty hello
royal obsessors i'm lauren zima and this
is a mug full of tea with Prince William
and Kate Middleton's faces on it yes I
cannot wait for the royal wedding to get
a mug with Harry and Megan so we are
here to count things down we're looking
at everything Harry and Megan are doing
ahead of the big day and this week
Prince Harry and Megan Markel took a
trip to Scotland and everybody so much
happened in such a short amount of time
they were only there about a day but the
couple took time saying hi to big crowds
outside of Edinburgh Castle it's a
historical fortress in the capital of
Scotland and fans had waited freezing
for hours they even put Megan and hare
his faces on flags this psycho is
definitely laughing in the code fall and
be still our hearts gathered crowds
means we got Harry with kids moments
look how cute he is Harry with the local
kids even kneeling down to speak to this
little girl as she stood in barricade
jail and then this sound happened guys I
truly don't know what it was a dog
barking a sneeze someone sobbing tears
of joy induced by incredibly
good-looking Royals if you figure it out
let us know for now we have another
mystery to solve a possible kidnapping
oh no that's just Harry's pitch-perfect
sense of humor as he chats with
strangers in the crowd and then a
different kind of love story on the
streets of Scotland Megan may have some
competition for Harry's heart it's proof
that Harry gets along with everyone and
everything this is him meeting the
mascot of the Royal Regiment of Scotland
Harry loves the pony the pony loves
Harry the pony has great hair Megan was
green with envy or at least her fabulous
Scottish strawberry purse was she and
the Shetland pony actually kind of
matched maybe the pony will be the next
addition to the royal family or maybe
not things really took a turn there
after all that animal excitement Harry
and Megan actually went inside the
castle where they had to wear some very
unfashionable earplugs
during the ceremonial firing of the gun
and they had tips shake lots of hands of
course
the hell dance and everyone wore tart
hands which are a cultural icon of
Scotland by the way underneath Meghan's
fabulous Burberry coat were once again
the 36 year old continued her trend of
wearing pants to events and we've got
the deets those amazing black
high-waisted trousers are by Veronica
beard and can be yours for a casual 395
dollars the code is much more almost
$3,000 so collect your coins kids the
pair also popped by the social bite a
sandwich shop that helps feed the
homeless now we do wish they'd put
monkey Harriet a bigger booth he is six
one after all and it looked crowded this
poor guy had to awkwardly pull up a
stool to join the conversation but the
consensus overall seems to be
overwhelming repetitive adoration
absolutely was really the really nice
couple are they a charming absolutely
charming and we cannot let you go
without a wedding update because even
though they are traveling the world
Harry and Megan are also planning a
pretty big party and we have news guys
they might have the world's top pop star
perform
yes the inside scoop is that a source
tells ET none other than ed Sheeran who
of course is a Brit has been asked to
sing yahoo Meharry once if I was free I
probably would a first dance to Ed
Sheeran live could be pretty romantic
speaking of it was Valentine's Day this
week so you might be wondering how did
the Royals celebrate amidst all this
Scottish fanfare well they'd left
Scotland and on Valentine's Day
Harry attended a dinner for the
environment with his dad did he forget
okay I did some digging and even though
Valentine's Day originated in England
Brits do not celebrate it as heavily as
Americans do and Harry did get a kiss
from dad plus look at this throwback we
found you guys so it's now defunct but
back in 2015 Megan Markell still had her
own blog and on it she advised her fans
to love themselves on Valentine's Day
writing quote I think you need to be
your own Valentine so our American
princess is all good on the self-love
front guys from ponies to wedding
performances that's the royalty for the
week but there's more a TT online.com we
have tons of royal coverage including to
die for photos of harry visiting a
school in london and a minute-by-minute
breakdown of the royal wedding day
itself we now know exactly what time
everything will happen so see you next
week with a cuppa cheerio
[Music]
you